hello everyone and welcome to the
long-awaited legends of chess tournament
uh featuring 10 of the
well current legends in the world of
chess some of them retired from
professional chess some of them uh still
active and before we check out the game
and talk a little bit about the time
format of this tournament
these are the legends uh image from the
chess 24 website so let's check it out
uh peter swiddler magnus carlson
vishwanathan and dingler and boris
girlfriend
vasily vanciuk anishigiri vladimir
kramnik janni pomnishi and peter leko
so uh this is going to be quite
quite a tournament and uh this is the
uh the the game that we're going to
start it off with it's
already an interesting game it's from
round two of the clash carlson versus
geary
uh it's similar as in the previous
tournaments there will be four rapid
games and if those four rapid games are
tied we're going to go into
uh uh faster time formats being
this one being an armageddon and uh the
the games are uh 15 min 15 15 minutes
per player
uh with a 10 second uh increments
starting from move one
so that being said uh let's check it out
uh as it's it's quite the game
and also if you're interested i've read
on twitter
uh chess historian olympia tweeted
that uh magnus carlsen is currently on a
boat trip and that he's playing this
tournament
uh from a boat now that being said let's
check it out magnus opens with d4
we have knight f6 by geary c4 and now e6
we have knight to f3 and of course we go
into the queen's gambit decline the d5
is on the board
uh and knight to c3 now we have bishop
to before geary goes for the ragosan
defense
uh and the bishop to g5 and it's only
move five but
it's already where the magic happens so
here uh gear replace h6
is the most common move here in the
position uh and
what you will usually see here is bishop
captures this is the main move and
bishop to h4 so these are the two moves
that are like
almost always played but magnus goes
back with bishop to d2
and it looks a bit weird you played
bishop g5 then you've kind of baited h6
but it's not really weakening black's
position i mean
if anything it is useful and then you
just bring the
your dark square bishop back so here uh
geary just
castles and it's again interesting that
castling is the strongest move
recommended by the engine here
but now known moves are c5 and e3 here
but magnus goes for g4
and it is as of move seven that we have
a completely new game on our hands
and uh it's uh it's not a new idea like
g4 has been seen many times here but now
uh you're in a rapid game it's not a
classical game where you can just uh
think you know forever and
come up with all sorts of defenses now
you have to deal with it and
already do captured you don't do do not
capture i mean
anything is possible uh so basically if
you capture the idea it's just rook g1
and then you kind of want to
exploit the idea that the the g file is
semi-open and that
that this bishop is extremely strong
here so point is if you go back just
bishop captures on h6 the g pawn is
pinned
and if you don't after rook g1 now let's
say you go h5 still after h3 knight goes
back you can still go for bishop to h6
and now it's a very unpleasant position
let's say 98 you have to defend this
otherwise you have to give give up the
rook so let's say g
instead of g6 you could go 98 to defend
the pawn
uh but now uh something like bishop g5
attacks the queen and the queen doesn't
have any good squares if this then
knight comes into
e5 if this uh then c5 is an
option so once once you play e3 the
knight moves you will be able to pick up
this pawn
so it's really uh not the the greatest
of positions for black
and even though if if it was playable
let's say in a longer time form it would
sound like f6
this is a rapid game and you you can't
really afford to play positions like
this so after g4
uh giri just captures on c3 with uh
with the bishop uh and now comes uh
bishop captures on c3 you could also
capture with the b
pawn saying that uh this might come in
useful also as maybe as
a preparation for g5 but magnus just
recaptures with the bishop he says
there is no rush gear he goes 94 now
puts pressure on the bishop here and
also uh makes room to
either bring the queen into game or to
expand with f5 in the future
so queen c2 now the queen also guards
the bishop
also if you capture then the knight will
be hanging so there's that
uh and also magnus prepares a nice queen
side castle so here gary goes c5
and now we have d captures on c5 uh
and here while gary could recapture
instead he just
continues with b6 he says your king is
still in the center of the board so i'm
just going to start attacking it
instead of allowing you to go for some
sort of an attack by grabbing a material
but carlson just continues with his
attack on the king's side the g5
and now of course he wants to open up
the g-file play rook g1 and continue the
attack
so here if knight captures which is of
course possible magnus would just castle
queen side play rook g1
h4 and so on he would enjoy the the
semi-open g file so gary instead goes
for h captures on g5
and now magnus just continues with h4
now he wants the h file to open up
but now of course g for by erie he wants
to close the position and he doesn't
want to give carlsen any open file so
knight
g5 and now there's the uh well of course
if the knight moves then queen h7 is
checkmate so you can't really do that
and white can always win the pawn back
if white wishes to although white
isn't really interested in something
like that white either wants the knight
to move or the h file to open up
so gary goes for f5 uh protects the uh
the knight
even more but now just bishop to g2 now
magnus just starts uh
uh continues his development he's gonna
castle queen side at some point and he's
not gonna rush anything on the king's
side
and now this bishop is is a beautiful
piece here
uh the the e6 pawn is somewhat weak and
well
there is still this diagonal is
extremely strong
so there's a lot to take into
consideration for black and also time is
running low so uh here we have b
captures on c5 he captures that
uh hoping to throw in d4 at some point
uh but
just queen side castles here and now you
don't really get anything by that
because after d4
you can't capture due to the rook being
aligned with the queen and after let's
say captures captures and captures
you now have the problem of checkmate
and the hanging rook on a8
so after this queenside castle we have
knight captures and g5 by geary knight
captures on c3
may be the the safer choice here but uh
gary decides to
to throw this one in as this comes with
also with check
so h captures and queen captures on g5
now delivering check and while magnus
could block this with the bishop
or the pawn sorry pawn or the bishop he
just continues with king to b1 says
there is no rush i'm just going to
capture on d5 and i'm going to have a
a nice position here so here knight to
d7
you don't really have an option here of
d4 or capturing as the rook would hang
on a8 so knight d7 by giri
and now c captures on d5 making it again
impossible to recapture because bishop
captures with
check and again you're you're in a huge
problem so you can't even
move the king anywhere since this row
covers the h file if you play rook f7
then
it's just you know it it's just terrible
uh plus there's a hanging rook there
so uh we have knight to b6 by geary now
preparing to capture here but now just d
captures an e6 opening up a discovery
here on the rook
and while you could play something
passive like rook to b7
gary says we're not going to be playing
anything passive we're just going to
play bishop captures on e6 give up the
exchange and hopefully
we will have enough resource to hold
this to a draw
so magnus accepts the rook we have
bishop capture 78
rook capture 78 and now queen to d2 now
he's up material of course he wants to
trade queens and
immediately queen d2 offers uh such a
thing so
queen g6 uh declining this also
preparing some discovery action with f4
uh but the queen d6 magnus says it's not
not an issue
so f4 with check uh magnus goes king to
a1 and now
now you could continue the game in a lot
of ways rook to e8 is an idea
uh you you could try to shift the knight
back into the game with knights to d7
however the mook
the mook the move geary plays is
a move that blunders the game on the
spot and it is with this move that we
reach to the position from the thumbnail
so feel free to pause the video and
check mate black uh
it's actually made in four moves so
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
deflecting rook to h8
check and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it's it is exactly
that sober okay check simply forces the
king away from the defense of the f8
rook
and it's game over so just team captures
queen captures with
check bishop blocks and now anything
goes rook h1
check king queen has to block and now
queen captures or even nicer bishop
captures is checkmate as
this is pinned so there is no no
capturing however uh
interesting as it is uh it seems that
magnus is also human
and he misses this he plays queen to e5
he prepares
ideas like okay now there's this battery
here going after the g7 pawn
so let's say rook h5 to g5 could uh
produce some
uh some quick wins here uh so gary goes
for g3
if anything he might be able to create a
pass pawn here
so f captures on g3 and first knight c4
bringing the knight into the game now
with an attack on the queen
queen the h5 offering a queen trade and
here
uh giri just accepts the queen trade so
we have captures captures
and now gary doesn't even bother with
capturing the g3 point yes it creates a
very nice pass pawn but rook g5 with
the double attack here will pick it up
so it's not really
anything to hope for so 93 by geary
going after this rook here
but now rook to g1 now again hoping to
open up the g file and go for that g7
pawn uh
it's the the same threat for the entire
game even with the queensland of the
board
so bishop to f5 uh and
now uh what do you do there could be
some knights to see to check
a check action king b1 and then the
knight might have some discoveries
uh so magnus goes to b3 first he doesn't
want to overthink it
and giri is the one who is extremely low
on time here i think magnus was around
four minutes here
and geary down to some 30 seconds so we
have f captures on g3
rook captures on g3 and bishop to g for
now blocking the g
file uh and uh well now attacking the
rook so if
rook captures here then bishop captures
rook so rook captures on c5 by magnus
getting broke out of harm's
way but now rook f1 checked by geary we
have king here and now knight to d
to check with a double attack but it's
not a problem as the bishop is quite
sufficiently defended
so king a3 and now knight captures on c3
we have
rook captures on g4 rook characters and
c3 is also
sufficient but magnus decides to go for
rook captures on g4 and it was in this
position on move 34
uh that uh anish geary resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
the knight is under attack once the
knight
moves out of the way then you can play
some like rook c8 check
king moves and then some like rook c7
and once you pick this guy and this guy
off
it's just game over there's there's no
continuing this and of course gary knows
this and uh he
resigns so very very nice start for
magnus in
round two of the of the chesable chess
masters uh but interestingly yeah after
rook to f8 it could have been a
beautiful miniature
uh like it's only moved 30 23 here where
rook to f8 was played and it's not
not a difficult tactic to spot but uh
magnus magnus found a different winning
idea so it's uh easy
to miss ideas like this these sometimes
so don't feel bad if you miss ideas in
your own games as that that's just how
chess works
so uh that's uh the game i do hope you
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
avicii banerjee carlos alcala stefan
tutzner thomas connors and
again and his friend ash uh natarina's
birthday was yesterday
uh interestingly again motorino and ash
both have their birthday birthday uh on
the same day as the uh
international chess days so if you think
about it it's it's it's almost like
destiny that
again motorino stumbled upon this
channel
so uh i wish you guys guys the best uh
sorry i didn't uh
uh mentioned it mentioned it yesterday
but i don't know how i forgot even your
donation uh matches your
birth date so sorry about that i got
maturing but i know you are you know
one crazy party dude you are probably
still celebrating uh ever since
yesterday so uh might
you know uh it might come just just in
the right moment
so once again i do hope you enjoyed it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the adjustable chest masters
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world ah see you soon